Speaker 1: We're starting today with the
topic of abortion. And this is a topic that
there was a period of time where it was less
of an issue. There was less of a question as
to whether Roe v Wade was going to remain the
law of the land. But now, with the Supreme Court
potentially just weeks away from issuing a ruling
that would uphold state restrictions on abortion,
which would effectively reverse Roe v
Wade, and the undue burden standard that
Roe v Wade contains, which we will get to
that we are seen expectedly as predicted,
more and more states passed the types of laws that
we have seen from Mississippi and from Texas and
from elsewhere. And the latest state to do this
is now Oklahoma. Oklahoma lawmakers have passed
a six week abortion, banned a ban modeled after
the Texas law that allows civil enforcement.
That's another element of this that is wacky,
retrograde stuff. Civil enforcement of this law.
And we will talk about why a six week
abortion ban is effectively just a ban
on abortion, which unquestionably would
violate Roe v Wade undue burden clause,
except Roe v Wade may be reversed. So let's read
about this first Associated Press reporting.
Oklahoma lawmakers Thursday gave final approval
to a bill modeled after the controversial Texas
abortion law. We knew every state that wants to
ban abortion is going to start using that type of
the they will use each other as models. It is a
law which allows private citizens to take civil
action against abortion providers as individuals
to enforce the law. It's a sort of vigilantism in
practice. The Oklahoma Heartbeat Bill, Heartbeat
Act Senate Bill 1503 would prohibit abortions at
the time when a physician can detect early cardiac
activity in an embryo or fetus. Now understand
that it is not. It had some like to say
it is a heartbeat. And doctors often say
it's this is reflexive cardiac activity.
To call it a heartbeat isn't even accurate.
That can be as early as six weeks into pregnancy
before many women even know they are pregnant.
The measure also provides exceptions for medical
emergencies. The state Senate later Thursday also
passed House Bill 4327, allowing private citizens
to sue abortion providers. House Bill 4327,
however, would prohibit abortions at any point of
pregnancy with exceptions for medical emergencies,
or if the pregnancy comes as the result of rape
or sexual assault, incest and is reported to
law enforcement. So there's two parts of this.
First, we've already talked because of the Texas
bill about this ability for an individual to
sue the abortion provider. It's another way
to put in this case, it's not only the
government between doctors and their patients,
but random people between doctors and their
patients, if anybody can bring a civil suit.
But I want to focus in on the six week ban thing,
because the defenders of this bill who want to
at least pretend about the rule of law, which is
Roe v Wade, established that generally speaking,
women should have access to abortion services and
that no undue burden should be placed on them in
order to obtain one. Now, undue burden is a legal
term that subject to interpretation, and this is
where I've been for 40 years, that that phrase
undue burden has been subject to interpretation
by courts at all levels. But a six week ban would
absolutely violate that and just think it through.
Many women most women don't know that
they're pregnant until 4 to 5 weeks. And
what I mean by that is, by the time you miss
a period and by the time most home pregnancy
tests can detect a pregnancy, you're already
considered to be four or five weeks pregnant
at minimum. If you at that point were to
say, hey, I got a positive pregnancy test,
I'm going to go to my doctor, my OB-GYN. They
will say, Oh, yeah, it's not your pregnant. And
it's the first week they would say you are
practically speaking for potentially five weeks
pregnant at this point of time. And if that if
the requirement is no abortions after six weeks,
what that means is you need to say, oh, well, I
need an abortion like tomorrow. And of course,
that is unreasonable. That is an undue burden,
even if one can decide that quickly, too.
If most of you have tried to get medical
appointments lately, you might know you don't
call and they don't give you an appointment for
tomorrow. That's generally a difficult thing to
do. So in practical terms, this is designed to be
a total abortion ban and it effectively would be
by enforcing the six week rule. We will see.
What happens in the Supreme Court. This bill,
this law will be appealed. Based on current law,
it would be found against Roe v Wade. It would
place an undue burden on women. You can't say six
week ban. Most women don't find out until week
four or five if they're pregnant. Right. So right
now, it would not it would violate Roe v Wade.
If in a few weeks, the Supreme Court says, well,
we're okay with this law and I believe it's
Mississippi that would effectively overturn Roe v
Wade and that would make it so that laws like this
one in Oklahoma and the one in Texas and others
likely would be allowed. And of course, this then
gets us into that situation where what happens? Do
people start fleeing red states for blue states,
or what is the right thing to do? What is
the expected thing to do? We don't know yet,
but this is exactly what we did. Go back to the
beginning. Go back to my shows when I was saying,
hey, you know, guys, I'm worried. This is this is
2016. I'm worried that there's too many people who
aren't taking seriously this issue of the Supreme
Court when they think about Trump versus Hillary.
They go, wow, I don't know if it's not going to be
this person, if it's not going to be that person.
Hillary Trump It's all the
same. And I would say, folks,
you have no idea what a few conservative Supreme
Court picks by Trump would do to this country. The
first thing they will do is they they're going to
try to ban abortion. And then Trump got one pick
and then he got a second pick and then
he got a third pick. And then we knew
they're going to start the state level bills.
The point of those bills is that they be appealed
all the way up to the Supreme Court. And the
Supreme Court might say no on the first one,
they might say no. On the second one, they might
not like some specific aspect of the third one.
But if they do it enough with this
right wing court, thanks to Trump
defeating Hillary and we have to be honest
that that's what put us in this position.
They may well overturn Roe v Wade. We
may be weeks from the end of Roe v Wade